well 2020 Democratic frontrunner Joe
Biden has been under fire for a string
of gas made on the campaign trail
most recently receiving heavy criticism
after failing to accurately tell a story
about his encounter with a war hero now
the former beeps on the defense the
details are irrelevant in terms of
decision-making and so the fact that I
would forget that it was Rodriguez who
was pinning I believe this is the case
pinning a Bronze Star on a young man was
it's it's irrelevant to the point it's
like saying I had this very bright
reporter and I think her eyes were blue
what difference would it make about
whether you were a bright reporter your
eyes are brown it's irrelevant and you
know it's a long time if you're Joe
Biden that's a long time to be the
frontrunner to be hanging out there as a
front-runner for 18 months that seems a
little bit hard
nobody could lay a glove on him so far
really in the polls he's consistently
been able to stay up there keeps leading
gloves on herself Bernie Sanders
actually literally did that last week I
thought the more devastating thing is
not the gaps I think that Democratic
voters who like Joe Biden they don't
care
I think that's ridiculous they're not
worried about it and what Biden that did
there a little bit is he's all walked
right up to the line of calling it fake
news and pushing back on the media
coverage I'm sure he's frustrated with
the media I thought the bigger problem
for the Biden campaign was a big piece
in the New York Times yesterday by or
Sunday by mark Leibovich and asking him
what is your rationale to be President
and really it's not sharp it's not there
it's it's basically like well somebody's
got a beat from and I think that
african-american voters who love him are
gonna stick with him that is going to be
something that is gonna be solid that's
not going to end and you can imagine
that the Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren supporters are like what are we
gonna do Elizabeth Warren is pulling
that 1% with african-american voters so
there is a big reckoning to come I don't
think it'll come for a few months but
the fact that he can't actually nail
down his answer for why he wants to be
President except for somebody has to
beat Trump that doesn't feel like it's
good enough to I'll build on what you
said Danny he would have to say that
Romney
if Romney was running what Biden was
prey or or Jeb was president he might
not have run
so then he said I'm the lone electable
I'm doing it for the party right Barak
Obama said Joe you don't have to do this
and then today he comes out and says I
think eight or ten of the other dads can
be Trump so he just undid his own
argument and what I think is most
damning his two things he was in charge
of paying out the stimulus package and
he was in charge of the pullout of Iraq
and if you read mattis's book today he
talks about interacting with bi and
trying to explain that the problems if
you pull out the way he wants to and
allow al-maliki to steal that election
and he just basically gave lip service
and did it anyway and we know we got
Isis in return those that's what that's
what a president biden would do i'd like
to build on that as well right that's he
gets the details and he gets the
decisions wrong because Barbara Gates
who's you know defense secretary
Republican and Democrat administration's
says Joe Biden has been wrong on every
single foreign policy decision in the
last 40 years if you think about it he
was against Reagan's push against the
Soviets during the Cold War he was
against Desert Storm he was against the
surge he was against the bin Laden raid
he was for regime change in Libya and
that means foreign after I mean you
could add all these things up so when
you combine the gaffes the poor
decisions the age and the sleepiness on
the trail it is a very nasty mix of
negatives that is going to drag him down
and the only reason he's up right now is
because because Warren and and Sanders
are splitting the left wing vote and
he's got great name ID but other than
that I think he's the weakest
frontrunner I've ever seen and he might
lose Iowa and New Hampshire and that
leaves him with V South Carolina yeah
that leaves him with whose strategy was
that Rudi's we all remember how that has
Miss Florida I think you're being kind
in in terms of the biology of it he's
only nine months older than I am but
they were right in Joe Biden okay but
they were oh thank you for sick you look
great it's the hair the that when he
misses the beat it really seems organic
to me it doesn't seem like he's going to
get sharper going forward he doesn't
seem to me that this is just
but warming up that he's gonna get in
there and he's gonna be more articulate
more confident in his presentation a
more eloquent more you know presidential
in a sense he seems tentative mm-hmm to
me is that that a and and the people
that are around him like they they hope
he doesn't break you know and I guess
not rust wants to make sure he doesn't
break cuz I think Trump wants wants him
to be his opponent yeah you know Brian
the argument with with Joe Biden as
being the front-runner is like he's
strong he's the one who has this in the
bag but when it comes down to going
against the Trump campaign jurgen odd
and Joe Biden clearly not really wanting
it considering he's saying that he you
know maybe wouldn't be in it if it
wasn't President Trump his wife having a
hard time selling his plan saying you
know his plan might not be the best one
he might not be the best candidate but
you should elect him to beat Donald
Trump is he really going to be able to
keep up when it comes to him taking
campaign stuff stops off of his schedule
right now when he's not even really in a
hard battle for the front right now
wait until next week's debate I mean
that's the third every time he goes into
a debate an unscripted situation it is a
carnival of a full pause so we can't
wait well I'll do without the other
opponents go after him like does
Elizabeth Warren it's not going to be
because he's a gaffe machine it will be
because of something like his coziness
with the credit card industry and China
but if he loses New Hampshire in Iowa
what happens well that's that's the
question is he going to lose that moment
about the front but the benefit for
nakum al Harris aren't doing well in the
early States either and Bernie Sanders
will lose both as well right so he's
still in a good position